je crois pour ma part que ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre est plutôt de
l'ordre d'une grande bascule ou d'un
grand bouleversement
d'abord parce que nous vivons et cela
pas simplement depuis cet été ces
dernières années au fond la fin de ce
qui pouvait apparaître comme une
abondance et 7 je dois le dire aussi la
fin pour qu'ils en avaient une forme
d'insouciance
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
jean-françois le régime de liberté de
vie dans lequel nous sommes habitués à
vivre peut supposer des sacrifices en
tout cas d'aller au bout de certaines
batailles à mener c'est la deuxième fois
qu'il parle de sacrifices en moins d'une
semaine vendredi il prévenait déjà les
français je pense à notre peuple auquel
il faudra de la force d'âme
pour accepter de payer le prix de notre
liberté
[Musique]
c'est nous
c'est quoi
des traits dans le pot
[Musique]
c'est vous
c'est la vie qui tue qui fait ça ne va
pas du tout vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé pendant qu vide tout le monde
était à la tâche tout le monde mais
juste
on a des bilans est ce que vous avez pu
mesurer à respecter est-ce que vous
allez respecter quoi mais je
m'attendais général et du pid ensuite je
me suis généraliste mais entendu jamais
non arrêtez votre argument d'autorité à
m mais les hippies alors vraiment une se
moque de tout et ne font que répéter
aimez vous et soyez heureux leurs dix
commandements les voici de la société
tut écartera de l'amour tu t'occupes ras
de la marijuana tu fumeras les sept
autres commandements étant les
corollaires des trois premiers ces
fumeurs de marijuana
voilà tout le monde et pour faire
quelque chose contre
du truc du numérique mais s'il
permettrait la bombe vous êtes quelqu'un
de gauche qui a aucun problème avant je
suis pas un gauchiste
je peux répondre
ces housses et la barre mais est le mien
j'ai mis six ans à fabriquer des dalles
à west pourrait voir
la capsule avec
attention la plus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé oms les français qui
conservent leur titre de plus gros
buveurs de rosé au monde venez citation
à vous tenez vous bien que c'est un
rapport de l'observatoire mondial du
rosé
ya vraiment une institution qui
s'appelle l'observatoire mondial du rosé
des gens qui regardent les autres boire
du rosé on se pense oui et c'est des
gens qui ne boira pas parce que sinon
qu'ils observeraient double et ce serait
évidemment un vrai problème elles sont
vieilles d'environ 113 millions d'années
ces traces de pas de dinosaures ont été
découvertes dans le lit d'une rivière
asséchée d'un parc au texas
à cause de conditions de sécheresse
excessive cet été la rivière s'est
complètement asséché dans la plupart des
endroits ce qui a permis de révéler des
traces laissées par un accroc quant aux
russes des traces conserver car elle
était en fouille est recouverte d'eau il
ya encore peu de temps fou spyros
l'oncle de caterina à 74 ans et il vit
depuis l'âge de 10 ans à hydra tu
trouves pas qu'avec la casquette je
ressemble à jean paul belmondo si vous
croyez que vous lui ressemblez tombe
bien la wii je lui ressemble avec ma
casquette ressembler comme deux gouttes
d'eau c'est bien simple bien sûr je suis
d'accord
la marque blanche du maillot sur les
fesses c'est très érotique voilà sexy ou
tue l'amour le parisien a fait un gros
dossier dessus moi je vous donne la
réponse oui me bats contre ça tombe sur
scarlett johansson c'est sexy comme
c'est gérard larcher
s'était réglée à
l'image c'est un claquage partout dans
le monde la sécheresse a déterré des
vestiges
en espagne à une heure de barcelone
l'église de saint romain de sow était
recouverte d'eau depuis les années 60
elle est désormais complètement visible
suite à l'assèchement de se marrer c'est
fabuleux de s'imaginer qu'ici c'était
rempli de milliers de litres d'eau
royaume-uni là c'est terrible voilà un
prêtre surpris en plein acte sexuel avec
denis s'est pas d'abord que la
tombe et l'aspirateur comme ça il a pas
l'air majeur l'aspirateur non plus qu'il
a certainement les prêtes et devrait
tenter avec un mix r comme ça je vais
vous dire une bonne fois pour toutes on
aurait réglé le problème
ce monde sait